ist das der durchbruch auf der suche
nach leben auf dem mars eine studie sagt
jetzt die seltsamen strukturen der der
curiosity go war letztes jahr auf dem
mars fotografiert hat sind spuren von
leben bot das wäre wirklich der hammer
klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich faszinierende wissenschafts
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen sind dass die
hinterlassenschaften eines mars wurms
wenn man so etwas hier auf der erde
finden würde wären solche fossilien ganz
klar tierischen ursprungs wir haben ja
hier schon öfter über leben auf dem mars
berichtet und die möglichkeiten dass es
tatsächlich zumindest in der
vergangenheit möglich war ja die sind
exorbitant immer wieder werden indizien
gefunden überall im all werden hinweise
darauf gefunden dass leben vielleicht
nicht die ausnahme sondern der
normalfall im weltall ist dann wäre der
mars einer der top-kandidaten für leben
was der mars rover curiosity am 15
dezember 2017 fotografiert hatte das ist
wirklich atemberaubend auf dieser
aufnahme sind oben auf einem stein
spuren zu sehen wie hier auf der erde
ganz klar lebewesen zugeordnet werden
würden als erstes berichtete der
amerikanische journalist david über die
entdeckung recherchierte weiter und
befragte wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler zu der entdeckung einer
war etwa wasser wada wissenschaftler vom
mars science laboratory so der kolosse
projekttitel er sagte zulehner david
über die möglichkeit dass es sich um
versteinerungen handelt also spuren von
leben
wir schließen es nicht aus aber das wird
sicher nicht unsere erste interpretation
sein und wenn einiges darauf hin deutet
ist noch fraglich ob die instrumente des
mars rover curiosity überhaupt
ausreichen um das zu bestätigen
die neuesten fotos bestätigt jedenfalls
den eindruck des tierischen ursprungs
sie sind rund ein bis zwei millimeter
dick und 5 mm lang wie die versteinerung
der hinterlassenschaft eines wurms der
astrobiologe barry di gregorio von der
university of buckingham
diese strukturen gleichen lebensspuren
aus dem auto wie sie umgesetzt schon
hier auf der erde untersuchen
fotografieren konnte und er hat jetzt
weiter geforscht er und seine kollegen
haben die struktur mit hilfe eines 3d
photogrammetrie bildanalyse programms
untersucht und er ist jetzt davon
überzeugt dass diese strukturen
tierischen ursprungs sind
es wäre spuren sogenannter biotop nation
das heißt dass ihr würmer oder muscheln
gänge hinterlassen haben sie sich dann
mit sediment gefüllt haben laut nasa
handelt es sich bei dem fundort harrell
zwick im geldkarte um einem ehemaligen
frischwasser see für di gregorio passt
damit alles zusammen
zitat die farbe und textur der
strukturen auf dem mars sind deutlich
dunkler als das sie umgebende gestein
die länglichen strukturen gleichen in
auffallender weise
plano ließ oder palast wie no i des
bauten des physischen ordovizium 585,4
bis 222,4 millionen jahren bei genauerer
betrachtung scheinen die strukturen in
das umgebungslicht 1 1 und daraus hervor
zu tauchen ganz genauso wie bei
spielerischer bioproduktion die größe
der strukturen auf dem mars ist circa 10
mm lang und scheint falschen
verzweigungen aufzuweisen die sich mit
anderen kreuzen
dieses merkmal spricht gegen die
vorstellung dass wir jetzt hier mit
einer struktur zu tun haben die durch
eine schrumpfende mineralogische ries
füllung entstand er widerspricht damit
der nasa interpretation nach der es sich
um rein mineralogische bzw kristalline
rückstände oder die reste von mit
forcierten sedimenten in hohlräumen
handelt sollte unsere hypothese also zu
treffen so würde dies bedeuten dass auf
den folien maß mit komisches und
mehrzellige 's leben vielleicht schon
eine milliarde jahre früher entstand als
auf der erde
ein frischwasser see auf dem mars vor
rund 3,5 milliarden jahren würde sah
nahelegen dass der mars und nicht die
erde die erste blaue murmel in unserem
sonnensystem war
während die nasa den fundort nicht näher
untersucht hat und eine chemische
analyse fehlgeschlagen ist wie di
gregorio unbedingt mehr über den fundort
erfahren ob er sich durchsetzen kann
wir bleiben auf jeden fall dran leben
soll ja auch auf exo planeten in der
habitablen zone rund um ihre heimat
sterne möglich sein raumzeit blockt der
zukunft stellt die fünf
vielversprechendsten 2018 entdeckten
exoplaneten hier vor unbedingt
draufklicken sehr sehr spannend die
stecken ja immer eine menge arbeit in
jesus also unbedingt abonnieren
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran